- Have you ever been in an
intense situation in life?
- In a couple.
- Okay, I've been in one.
I can't wait to hear yours.
- Yeah,
there were two that came to mind.
One was my, car is spinning
out on the freeway,
ending up facing oncoming
traffic in the far lane
that for like a split second, I thought,
oh, maybe I'm on the shoulder. No.
- Did you hit ice.
- I didn't hit ice.
- Okay, I hit ice. And the
same thing happened to me.
Keep going.
- And then like an 18
Wheeler truck is like,
I see it, it's coming
at me, and I just went,
okay.
- Yeah.
- I just.
I didn't scream. I didn't
know, it's just sort of this
calm of what's coming.
And then, you know, I was
held up at knife point
and you know, just fun,
- What
- Fun things
- Wait.
- Just you know, things that happened.
- And I was held up at knife.
- Held up at knife point you know.
- No, wait, what, why, or where, when?
- I was working at a clothing store,
in a little boutique
on the upper west side, in New York city.
And it was my weekend gig.
When I was in high school
and
guy came in,
and we had this whole system, right?
Cause we knew the people next door.
And I kind of knew that there
was that there was a something
he didn't smell right to me
because like, again, I'm porest.
I can feel these things, right?
So he didn't feel right to me.
So I called next door
and I gave the password
and then wait, they'd forgotten
what the password was.
They had absolutely no idea
what I was talking about.
And they're like, oh are you ok okay,
They did, I did all the
things I'm supposed to do?
And they're like, huh, what?
And then it was just, out.
- You were left hanging out to dry.
- I was left, hanging out
to dry, but I was calm.
- Wow.
- I was cool.
- So, I have been in an
accident to where my car,
we hit ice, and it was like
New Year's Eve one year,
and I went backward and I do,
remember everything was in slow motion.
Cause my car kept an, and I can
hear my breath literally go.
I was like, and that's
all I remember hearing.
But there was this other time
my friend were four wheeling
out in the middle of nowhere.
And he literally like could have died.
Like the four Wheeler came back on him.
It went the wrong way.
And I found out who I
am in that situation.
I grab, I've got like a
survival not kit, like a,
like a whole house hold
full of like things,
in case something happened.
And so I ran and I got my
whistle and I just freaked out,
started blowing my whistle.
No one could hear the whistle,
my ex-husband and my
sister, everybody was like,
what are you doing? I was just like,
I was like somebody find us.
I freaked out. I'm not who you want in.
- You had the whistle.
- I had everything,
I was like you want to build a fire?
You want to, I was like
what do we need to do?
And I just grabbed the
whistle and freaked out,
and blew a whistle. Like a lot.
I freak out. I'm not who
you want on your team.